a season of loneliness and isolation is
when the caterpillar gets its wings
remember that next time you feel alone
remember
the time you feel lonely
is the time you most need to be by
yourself
life's cruelest irony
sometimes it's better to be alone
no one can hurt you
Eagles Fly alone
sheep Graves and herds
sometimes you have to stand alone just
to make sure you still can
loneliness is for the strong
the weak always huddle with the crowd
you cannot be lonely if you like the
person you're alone with
in order to understand the world
one has to turn away from it on occasion
smart people do not so much seek
Solitude as avoid the fuss created by
fools
to live a spiritual life
we must first find the courage to enter
into the desert of our loneliness
and to change it by gentle and
persistent efforts into a garden of
Solitude
loneliness adds Beauty to life
it puts a special burn on sunsets and
makes night hair smell better
grass is looking for crowds of its own
kind on the Earth
the tree is looking for its loneliness
in the sky
Solitude sometimes is best Society
if you are never alone
you cannot know yourself
it's good for a person to spend time
alone
it gives them an opportunity to discover
who they are
there is a certain strength in being
alone
loneliness is The Human Condition
cultivated
the way it tunnels into you allows your
soul room to grow
the more solitary the more friendliness
the more unsustained you are
the more you will respect yourself
in solitude
everyone sees in himself what he really
is
if you wanted to do something absolutely
honest something true
it always turned out to be a thing that
had to be done alone
perhaps only people who are capable of
real togetherness
have that look of being alone in the
universe the others have a certain
stickiness
they stick to the Mass
Whoever has a cat
cannot be afraid of loneliness
communication is overrated
sometimes an hour of solitude is more
productive than a week of talking
The Secret of a good old age is simply
an honorable pact with solitude
if you are alone you belong entirely to
yourself
if you are accompanied by even one
companion
you belong only half to yourself
to be of good quality
you have to excuse yourself from the
presence of shallow and callow minded
individuals
loneliness doesn't mean you're weak
it means you are strong enough to wait
for what you deserve
Solitude is a chosen separation for
refining your soul
isolation is what you crave when you
neglect the first
our language has wisely sensed these two
sides of man's being alone
it has created the word loneliness to
express the pain of being alone
and it has created the word solitude
to express the glory of being alone